in syria's major port city of latakia  the sound of airstrikes thunder in the  distance  as fireballs light up the night sky  this is the result of israeli missiles  according to syrian state media  the syrian government also reports that  residential buildings a hospital shops  and containers were all damaged in the  attack  details that could not be independently  verified  the port of latakia is in the west of  the country and handles most of syria's  imports  this is the second reported israeli  airstrike there this month  the earlier attack happened on december  7th and also targeted the container  facility  it was reported to be the first on the  facility since the start of the war in  syria in  2011. his missile strikes on latakia  were larger than the previous ones  israel's military has not commented on  either of the airstrikes  but it has previously confirmed  conducting raids against iranian targets  inside syria  mohammed al jazeera